what's up guys real quick breaking news
today the federal reserve chairman
jerome powell was asked by one of our
elected officials did he plan or intend
to eventually ban bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies jerome powell said no
there is no plan or intention to ban
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies really
important development here one of the
biggest reasons why people are bearish
on these assets or tend to wait to
invest in these assets is because they
think that governments and nation states
are going to crack down on it they're
going to prevent people from adopting it
or eventually they're going to some of
what they did in gold tell everyone to
turn in their assets to the us
government again doesn't mean that the
federal reserve chairman has the final
say but just another step in the right
direction where we learn that it is very
unlikely that bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies will end up being
banned in the united states it doesn't
really make sense to ban it we just saw
china go through it and actually ban the
assets now why would they do that well
it's an authoritarian centrally planned
country and economy they want control
they do not want their individual
citizens to have any sort of say or any
sort of control over their own lives
it's centrally planned but here in the
united states bitcoin is as american as
apple pie sovereignty freedom liberty
individual rights every single thing
that america stands for in this
democratic capitalistic society is
embodied in bitcoin bitcoin is making
the environment better by taking gas
flare capture literally taking one of
the most toxic things we put into the
environment capturing it preventing it
from being spread into the air and being
able to mine bitcoin with it it's pretty
damn cool on top of that what we are
watching is there's all sorts of
demographics in the u.s whether it's age
based education based wealth-based or
race-based that now are having access to
financial services that they previously
didn't have access to this asset has the
potential to change people's lives for
the better it is a decentralized
peer-to-peer payment system meaning you
do not need permission from anyone to
send it to anyone else on the network
there is no central third party that can
debase the currency that can actually
make you less wealthy if you simply save
in it so just like the fiat dollar or
the us dollar ends up going down in
purchasing power over time bitcoin is
the opposite it ends up going up in
value over time because it has a finite
supply and as demand increases the us
dollar price has to go up to accommodate
for everyone that's just the structure
when we think about this asset of course
people are going to run and adopt it
when you have a monetary and fiscal
policy situation that is
hurtful to
45 of americans who hold no investable
assets the rich are getting wealthy
regardless whether they hold bitcoin or
not they hold assets and as you devalue
the dollar you're going to pump those
asset prices up that's what we've been
watching hack for the last 18 months or
so
but now now that other people are
getting in the game those who had no
investable assets are starting to buy
bitcoin as well so you have institutions
and individuals there's been that
concern of whether the united states was
going to go ahead and ban bitcoin ban
cryptocurrencies we've seen bans occur
in nigeria pakistan and other countries
but in those countries like nigeria and
pakistan when the ban was put in place
we saw adoption go up users said why
does my country not want me to
participate in this they actually went
and they adopted it more we saw
everything from peer-to-peer
transactions go up the amount of people
responding to surveys saying that they
owned bitcoin went up and also mining
activity in those countries went up so
this is a decentralized network it
cannot be banned countries are much
better off embracing it rather than
banning it now that china has actually
kicked out the miners and banned
cryptocurrency transactions the united
states has an opportunity we just heard
from the federal reserve chairman that
he has no intention nor his organization
to ban bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
the us that means we should capitalize
on this we should go full on and embrace
bitcoin cryptocurrencies and we should
do our absolute best to get them in the
hands of as many americans as we
possibly can because this is the ability
for america to extend its dominant
position on a global stage if anyone is
going to benefit from these technologies
america must make sure that it is us
we must remain the leader on a global
stage and the best way to do that is to
embrace bitcoin and cryptocurrencies and
so hopefully that is what we will do but
pretty damn cool to see the chairman of
the federal reserve today coming out and
answering that question and saying that
we will not have bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies banned in the united
states based on his intentions or his
plan as of today hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did make sure you like
the video make sure you subscribe to the
channel i'll see you guys all tomorrow
for the live stream show what's up guys
bang bang thanks so much for watching
the best business show today if we're
gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]